when Timothy shalamay was first
announced as the newest actor to take on
the famous role of Willie Wonka there
was one actor in particular that fans
were saying they could have easily
imagined snagging the part Jeremy Allen
White plays Cari on the hit FX dramedy
the bear he took on the role after a
long run as lip Gallagher on the
Showtime series Shameless it's clear
that white is an actor with a lot of
talent and a massive fan base but these
weren't the traits that made folks on
the internet think he was a shuin for
the role of a young Willie Wonka rather
than a classic remake Wonka is more like
a prequel of this film so some people
were hoping to see a version of young
Willie Wonka in this movie that looked
like he could actually grow up to be
Jean Wilder's version of willly Wonka
one day once folks suggested that Jeremy
Allen White definitely fit into this
category the internet couldn't stop
thinking about just how much he looked
like a young Jean Wilder